j'ai eu un premier prix aujourd'hui de
quoi de lecture et ratures vous n'êtes
pas bien j'en tire c'est quoi télé
loisirs mais les meilleurs chroniqueurs
s'il vous plaît non non non mais t'as
les voiles et les cours comme ça
franchement je m'en occupe pas du tout
voulu excusez moi c'est à dire du tout
on a fait un concours de dès qu'ils
étaient beaucoup plus en plus ça se fait
ça c'est de la télé oui
selon ce même sondage j'ai été élu mais
en plus le cas pour sa part à regarder
qui est numéro 2 1 re s il vous plait
non mais je suis prêt je m'en fout rien
de ça je m'en fous toujours le même
sondage jeter les lois moi j'ai été élu
meilleur a dit m
[Applaudissements]
je ne fais pas du tout attention à ce
genre de sondage
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment faire
l'émission qui fait aux victoires oui
jean michel oui mais enfin quand même
tpm péter les élus meilleur talk show de
l'année c'est vrai non mais c'est pas là
bon voilà oui oui voilà oui c'est sympa
voilà oui ça fait plaisir
et cerise sur le gâteau lance ton post
3e ça fait bien vers les étoiles
[Applaudissements]
alors on actions à faire la même source
oui et cerise sur le gâteau évidemment
le mozart du paf a été une fois de plus
meilleur animateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je trouve vous me parlez plus je trouve
que ce sondage est intéressant je me dis
il faut quand même s'y pencher ah oui ah
oui ah oui et vous avez on n'a rien
prévu un professionnel honnêtement on
voulait faire quelque chose mais les
chiffres sont tombés en fin d'un milieu
d'après midi on a voilà on a été un peu
pris par le temps n'a rien de spécial à
tout petit truc mais franchement rien
mais en plus vous êtes modeste vous
aimez pas trop et c'est avec un tout
petit truc je sais pas s'il avait prévu
un petit truc comme un tout petit truc
c'est quoi un magnifique passion c'est
quoi
[Applaudissements]
c
mr
[Applaudissements]
les honneurs les trucs dont je voulais
parler vous les comprenez je n'étais pas
là pour ça
face à vous va bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais m
avant
oh
[Musique]
m
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
c
[Applaudissements]
on aimerait avoir un petit discours de
kenny mais novelli merci à télé loisirs
au vert c'est surtout c'est plus joli
merci et encore une parade militaire
séraphine si vous les séries messieurs
merci et surtout les téléspectateurs et
les gens qui ont voté parce que c'est
grâce à eux
ces réactions twitter la vallée au vote
et grâce à des mots forts et franchement
vous dis à chaque fois qu'on a besoin de
vous vous êtes incroyables et c'est
encore grâce à vous voilà tout ça plus
de 350 mille votes sur télé loisirs.fr
ça a été
voilà et non et kelly mais dvd ou d'être
meilleur chroniqueur s'invite comme dit
à peine un petit dit empirus va écouter
c'est grâce à vous vous êtes incroyables
si les gens qui merci aux gens les
secours toutes les personnes qui ont
voté pour moi je m'y attendais mais
vraiment mais pas du tout mais
absolument pas c'est maxime qui m'a
envoyé un petit message me dit en me
disant ça des fois je le croyais pas
j'ai même cru qu'ils aient truc est
aussi un nom sur le clip est sûre je
voulais aussi remercier cyril parce que
c'est grâce à l'entente celui-là bravo
le rassure elle n'a pas eu l'air pas
dedans non plus ses traits d'abord temps
franchement apporter ses 70 ans et je
voulais je vous dis la vérité en vrai la
palme d'or je m'emballe agathe mais oui
mais voilà il ya aussi tout ce que je
m'en reste plus qu'une l'accident s'est
passé un truc de tri car bonne nouvelle
ça c'est la france voit la courbe
nouvelle arthur a eu 2 % ben oui mais
bon ils fêtaient aux professionnels aux
audiences
on rigole tuberie nous aimons bien il le
sait il adore ça donne ça il le sait sa
meilleure animatrice valérie bénaïm du
temps mort parce qu'on est très pressé
et bien un mot tous les jours vous dire
merci merci à toi syrie parce que ça
fait messi parce que cette année c'est
tu m'a permis d'être devant de dire aux
gens je les aimais et les ont ils me
l'ont rendu à 1 9%
la brève du coup de peau de chamois pour
terminer les bookmakers
la vérité c'est lui qu'il ya eu l'idée
de me produis me produire dans cette
émission est bien compris vous pouvez
dire merci à julien courbet de cette
variation maxime roy s'est ré écouter et
vous m'y attendais mais je suis hyper
content que ce soit vous by poste dans
la maison
[Applaudissements]
super doble et ça m'a fait très plaisir
et merci encore on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir des mêmes follower pourra par
exemple maxime bravo maxime avoue la
pensionnaire pendant l'été les baguettes
émérite il faisait 10 appels par le
rouge
allez merci alors elle est celle de mon
père doit tout le monde en effet c'est à
tout le monde est bienvenu alors je vais
le reverra pas vraiment plus ancien
maire qui symbolise tous cas on voit ce
qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient aller ni je
pars dans la montagne
en face à cela les deux minutes en euros
oui ben non mais c'est bientôt la fin
d'année en plus on va commencer la
dixième année
c'est vrai je suis là depuis le 1er
avril 2010 et tout le monde de façon
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde a
débuté - une grande famille moi je suis
ravi on se marre de plus en plus et à
boulot comme ça où on va au travail en
sachant qu'on va se marrer français avec
le docteur sa bonheur de tous les jours
as-tu ces longs mois alors merci et je
vais remercier voilà téléspectateurs et
tous les gens qui ont fait voilà que
voilà c'est ça que je vais le mettre
dans ma dans ma chambre
le rugby voilà donc merci à vous
merci à dire merci maxime venu lui aussi
sait pas communiquer voilà les chiffres
merci à tous et on va essayer encore
d'être meilleur et de ne jamais vous
décevoir les cherry en tout cas merci
d'être là et nous avoir jamais lâcher on
vous aime de ouf vraiment hélas et ses
très sincères et vous merci parce que je
sais que nous sommes deux roues ou sais
c'est que merci merci et bravo pour
cette démo ils peuvent rester en vie bon
ben dilla
ils font ça sur le facebook live ont
trouvé dans un instant remerciant tout
cas d'être venu
[Applaudissements]